Now let's implement the method which returns the plural form of a word. We'll
make some simplifying assumptions because plurals in English has a lot of
rules. Check out the Wikipedia article if you don't believe me, or if you think
phoenetics are interesting. We're just going to look at regular plurals, like
dish, which becomes dishes. Or cherry, which becomes cherries. Or clock, which
becomes clocks. Here are the rules I want you to implement for the initial
version. If you want to make a more comprehensive version, nothing's stopping
you, but get these ones down first. If the word ends in y, preceded by a
consonant, take away the y an add ies, like in cherries. If the word ends in y
preceded by a vowel, just add s, like in day which becomes days. If the word
ends in o, s, sh, or ch, add es, likes in dishes. Otherwise, just add an s. You
can use the is vowel and is consonant methods that you wrote before, as well as
another method that I added. The method is takes an index, and the letter to
compare it to, and returns true if the letter at that index matches the letter.
There's also a tester program with a bunch of examples of correct plural
spellings of the words. As a bonus, what happens if you give your program a
single letter word, like a. What if you give it an empty string? Does it crash?